so over the last 23 years we've been
studying the center of the galaxy with
the largest telescopes in the world of
the telescope and by developing new ways
of using this telescope to get to the
diffraction limit we've been able to
open up a new way of studying
supermassive black holes and that's by
watching the orbits of stars as they
orbit the center of our galaxy the Milky
Way
these orchestras of evil to show that
there is a supermassive black hole the
senator of our galaxy this is the best
evidence to date that to the rest of
black holes exist not only in the center
of our galaxy but anywhere in the
universe
and by continuing to measure the
absorbance the time and geology helps we
have the ability to explore the physics
a supermassive black hole
in other words testing how black hole
warp space-time as well as The Exorcism
of supermassive black hole will rule
these objects play in the formation and
evolution of galaxies the only galaxy in
which we can watch this interaction that
we think is key in the evolution of the
universe at play